all right i'm going to go ahead and get
started as more people
filter in
thank you so much for joining us for the
urgency for action at cop26 what will a
fair deal look like
this is the ninth in the series the l
development dialogues which is a series
of virtual panel discussions hosted by
yale's economic growth center the
jackson institute for global affairs and
also yale's history department i'm
catherine chaney i'm a journalist
focused on development and i'm thrilled
to moderate these conversations looking
to lessons from history and economics as
well as policy and practice to address
today's policy challenges in low and
middle income countries
today i'm joined by several panelists
i'll quickly introduce them and then
i'll let them go into more depth about
their connection with this topic john
haldon is a professor at princeton
university who directs the climate
change and history research initiative
which is an interdisciplinary project
that investigates the societal impact of
climatic changes across the last two
millennia
sunita narayan is a writer and
environmentalist who is director general
of the india-based research institute
for the center
for science and environment as well as
editor of down to earth
nicholas ryan is an assistant professor
of economics at yale whose work examines
energy policy in india
and rohini panda is henry j heinz ii
professor of economics and director of
the economic growth center at yale
so before i hand it over to our
panelists i just want to provide a
little bit of context and i'll ask
rohini to expand on this in a moment as
she's really helped to spearhead this
session
but according to a report from oxfam
released earlier this year the richest
one percent of the global population
have used two times as much carbon as
the poorest 50 percent over the last 25
years
now climate is the top threat to public
health and its impacts on humanity from
droughts to rising sea levels to
worsening air pollution will hit the
poorest the hardest
some wealthy nations are calling for
lower income countries to pursue
renewable energy rather than fossil
fuels even as they themselves continue
to rely on those sources of energy
that leads some to call for a just
transition and that's what we'll be
discussing today
i was tuning in to some of the sessions
at the united nations general assembly
recently and was struck by what the
prime minister of barbados had to say
and really thought it related to this
conversation so here's just a quote from
her
she said
how much more must sea levels climb in
small island developing states before
those who profited from the stockpiling
of greenhouse gases contribute to the
loss and damage they have occasioned
rather than asking us to crowd out the
fiscal space that we have for
development to cure the damage caused by
the greed of others so that's just one
example of where there's a real source
of tension when it comes to who is being
asked to make what commitments uh as we
look ahead to cop 26. so today we'll
focus on the commitments of high and low
income countries to address climate
change in the context of the upcoming
united nations climate change conference
of the parties or cop 26 taking place in
glasgow from october 31st to november
12th
and our panelists will discuss climate
policy from a lower income country
perspective and also consider who is
responsible for the cost of reducing
emissions
for those of you joining on zoom we
really want to make this a conversation
we welcome your questions so please use
that q a function in zoom keep those
questions coming and i'll get to as many
as i can
but without further ado i want to bring
our panelists into this and we'll start
with rohini so before we get to cop26
specifically i just want to ask each of
our panelists to expand on how their
work informs their perspective on this
intersection of climate change and
social justice so i briefly introduced
you all but rohini can you expand on
where you come at this question
so let me start by noting the fact that
the nobel prize in physics today went
for work that was seen to be
important for climate change
and i and i think a lot of initial work
in thinking about issues of climate
change has come from science or from
engineering and thinking about issues
with technology
what i've been interested in is asking
what perspective can economists
especially those who think about
implementation issues and the political
economy bring to it and i think
repeatedly i have seen in much of my
work some of it with uh nick is that um
we
fail when we don't think of designing
institutions and policies that take into
account both
what citizens want but importantly
what's just feasible given the
institutional structure in that place
and so looking ahead to cop 26 i know
there'll be many points where
lawyers are having discussions and there
are many points where
leaders of countries will have
discussions
and
you know what i would love to see is
some more discussion uh of
what
how will you translate any policies you
come up with or any
targets you come up with on the ground
given the constraints that exist and
what does that mean for what would
happen so that's really the perspective
i'd love to bring catherine
thank you rohini and i agree we'll make
sure that we talk about policies and
their impacts on the ground today um i
want to bring john into this and i'll
note that when john and i were first
interacting about the possibility of him
joining us as a panelist he talked about
how his lens on history goes way back
which he can tell us a bit more about in
a moment and he wasn't sure you know was
that the right addition to this
conversation or do we want someone
focused on more recent history
i just want to say i'm thrilled to have
your perspective looking way back and i
know some of the points that you're
going to make um from a long time ago
are going to be hugely relevant to
discussions on what's coming up at cop26
so john tell us a little bit more about
your work and how that informed your
perspective on this climate change
social justice intersection
thank you catherine and thank you to the
organizers for inviting me to be part of
this conversation i think um the big
question is can can history tell us
anything about how to address
contemporary problems
um
and the short answer is yes it can but
probably not in the way that one expects
it to be able to do
um so the first thing is that um
when one looks at the the past whether
it's the deep past uh let's take
neolithic societies for example about
which we can say
quite a lot uh through the
archaeological record and paleoclimatic
records
stretching right up to recent pre-modern
times when one looks at these different
societies one thing stands out and that
is that
resilience and sustainability has been a
hallmark of human societies from the
very earliest times and indeed um
most societies have shown a remarkable
degree of resilience against even the
harshest sorts of challenges
um what tends to make a crucial
difference is uh a societal structure
and uh internal social relationships but
crucially um belief systems and cultural
attitudes these are really really
important and i think they're one of the
things
that
when one looks for example the un's list
of
sdg's sustainable development goals
one of the things that doesn't really
have much presence there are is
attitudes attitudes to change attitudes
to challenges
attitudes to social and economic
relationships and so forth
they're there they're implicit but
they're not addressed
explicitly and they need to be and the
historical record and the archaeological
record
can actually tell us quite a lot about
that
um and that seems to me to be a very
significant contribution that looking at
the past uh can make
i love that and uh your point on
attitudes uh implicit uh but maybe not
addressed in in the way they should be
in the sdgs i think that's well taken
and the same could be said for climate
policy um
attitudes and the importance of
attitudes um i'd love to go to sunita
next if that's all right
um sunita i know you're working day in
day day out on these issues and that
it's late your time um so we really
appreciate you joining us but can you
talk a little bit more about your work
which i only briefly previewed um and
and basically what is your key message
or the things you want to get into today
when it comes to uh what a fair deal
looks like a cop 26
yeah kathryn i mean john gave us an
amazing
beginning and
you know for me history doesn't go back
that long but a little bit of recent
history i was in rio when the framework
convention on climate change was signed
and i was there because we
we had my colleague
who passed away he and i actually worked
on a publication called global warming
in an unequal world a case of
environmental colonialism and this was
1991
and the report essentially was a report
which argued that if you did not have a
fair and equitable agreement
you could never have an effective and
ambitious agreement
and unfortunately uh catherine over the
last
30 odd years we have seen
the pushback has always been to try and
erase the concept of equity and to a
large extent we did succeed in paris
but
the fact of the matter is it is real
you can't really wipe out something that
is real and it's real because
um even if the rich are
polluted in the past uh the poor will
pollute in the future and so unless you
have a collaborative agreement
and one which everybody thinks is fair
and believes is fair
you will not have an agreement which is
effective and that actually came
and just to add the the reason we did
this report and actually that work has
was uh because we were working in india
and the work in india and i've always
said this and i've written it that our
work on climate change was very
influenced by our work on forestry in
india where we understood that the goats
uh which people kept in villages would
eat up any forest unless
the
people who had the goats knew that they
would get benefits from the common
forest that existed and subsequently all
the work that we have done and i
continue to do whether it's on air
pollution where nick has done a lot of
work or
on excreta and water because our work is
much more my work is in india we have
found the the abiding principle has been
that if it is not affordable growth if
it is not inclusive growth it cannot be
sustainable growth in india our biggest
issue with air pollution is because we
do not have mobility for all
and unless we have mobility for all we
will never have clean air unless we have
clean energy for all we will never have
clean air so the airshed has won and
that's something we have learnt uh
because of the horrendous pollution that
we have in our cities but it is very
much the same story on climate change so
i my work has been influenced both by
what i know in india
at the global level and also the
frustration at the global level
has only made us believe that
understand that we need to do much more
to make the right policies in our own
countries
thank you and we'll get into what that
looks like um just a couple reactions
one thing i hope to get to in our
conversation when you talked about
trying to erase the concept of equity um
is how kobit 19 has
really i think reintroduced the concept
of equity to our global conversation
into conversations on climate change so
that's something i want to hear from our
panelists on in a little bit
but first i do want to bring nick into
this and you mentioned nick's work in
india and on air pollution and i do
think i'm thrilled to have nick's
perspective because air pollution is a
very
concrete way to ground this all in an
example of how climate change affects
people's daily lives and how policies
can benefit people um in their daily
lives versus these you know
conversations at cop26 that often can
feel removed from people's day-to-day so
nick can you talk a little bit more
about your work in india and how it
informs your perspective on this
question
sure so i study energy markets and also
environmental regulation and i think a
goal of my work is to try to
break down this idea
that everything is zero sum so zero sum
is the idea that you know if you
regulate the environment it's going to
be costly and that that will slow down
industrial growth or
um that will inhibit you know
social and political development
and the way that i sort of try to do
that is studying markets where there's
some feature that doesn't work very well
apart from just the environmental harm
and see how that could be improved so
for example one of the you know great
triumphs in energy access has been that
in the last 10 years or so almost all of
rural india has been electrified and if
you look at that from a climate point of
view um people in you know developed
countries sometimes have reservations
about that that very poor people are
getting on the electricity grid uh for
the first time uh but i think that
that's you know efficient and the the
right investment to be made and that's
happening in part because of things like
drops in the prices of renewable energy
that make it more affordable to supply
grid electricity so there are cases like
this um not to say that they're the only
or the dominant case where you can get
um
win-win kind of situation where there's
investment um that investment is
sponsored in part by you know imported
solar panels coming from china or
technological developments that were
originally due to you know scientists
working all over the world but it
actually brings energy to poor people
rather than um denying it and i think to
to sumita's very important point and you
know her sort of paper in 1991 was very
far
ahead of its time in in terms of
there is no progress without equity and
what you see now
um the transition from the old kyoto
system to the now post para system is a
system where countries put forward their
own targets and so it was exactly an
institutional acknowledgement albeit
20-odd years late uh 20-odd years behind
this paper that we're not going to make
any progress unless countries are making
their own pledges and trying to stick by
those for for their own motivations
which which would include economic
development
thank you nick i want to i want to stick
on the topic of air pollution for a
moment um
and you know speaking of the impacts of
copen 19 on this space as we all know
lockdowns led to improved air quality
outdoor air quality and kind of raised
awareness of the kinds of drastic
changes that will be needed for us to
see
an impact in our surroundings but the
pandemic also brought renewed attention
to the issue of indoor air pollution so
i just wonder if if any of our panelists
want to expand on uh why now might be a
unique window of opportunity to tackle
the issue of air pollution and how again
that connects to
um what a fair deal looks like
maybe rohini do you want to jump in on
this
sure i'm not sure kobet necessarily
makes me very optimistic about global
action because i think some of what we
see is a lot of inward looking
nationalism uh on vaccines and
those issues having said that of course
at an individual level it's a point in
time where people may find it's a way to
change behavior that improves outcomes
but i think one interesting fact that
a student i know is working on is really
this question of
how do you how do you trade off
individual activism with system level
change so i think and i think cop 26 is
a good point to reflect on this that you
very often have
people making individual pledges like i
will travel less or i will
not eat meat
but perhaps those change sometimes you
do that and then you believe you don't
actually need to engage in activism or
you don't need to engage in larger
system change because you've made your
trade off
um but you know we know that that's not
going to be enough so i think one thing
the two things about kovid that i would
highlight is
one is i think made countries very aware
that they have to look out for their own
interests
um and i don't know how that's going to
play out and be curious to hear what
panelists think that will do
and then the other i think is you know
it's made people aware of their own
choices and whether that's actually
going to push them to make even push for
a larger change of the system level or
feel like i've done my part i can rest
there
okay two great points i'd love to hear
reactions to and um
john i'd also love to hear how you think
history plays into this but when rohini
outlines uh covet has made people aware
of their own choices covet has made
countries aware they have to look after
their own interests um
actually i mean can we go back in
history a little bit john and i know
this is something you and i discussed in
preparation
uh for this discussion
what history can teach us um
as we're sort of at this crossroads um
and then we'll kind of get into the
impact of covid and bring uh sunita nick
into this
yeah i mean i think the real the real
issue is motivating people to want to
make changes so as rohini said you can
get individuals certainly at certain
levels within a society um to make um
family-based or individual choice
changes which impact their own lives
uh directly and they're willing to make
those changes but unless there is a very
substantial cumulative impact
um they at least to begin with appear to
have very little um overall effect but
it's the motivation aspect that i think
is interesting certainly looking at the
past
um
when people are directly threatened or
challenged they'll act and they often
act very quickly and very effectively
and that goes right back to ancient
times where you can see responses to
floods um
cataclysmic
climate events and so forth
when you get rapid
visible
impacts people respond to them
not always effectively
but often enough to enable survival and
sustainable um economic life
after the impact
um
the cost of course varies according to
context sometimes the cost can be
enormous uh involving great loss of life
even though the society as a whole might
come through it
on other occasions where some degree of
infrastructural planning
for for example flooding has taken place
and there are plenty of cases where
that's uh that can be demonstrated very
clearly
and the losses can be minimized
there's a short-term hit but the overall
impact can be minimized
so motivation then
i suppose what i'm saying is depends on
how
directly it affects the individuals or
the communities in question but then
there's also the point at which cultural
and belief systems intervene because you
can have a very direct impact and people
will continue to deny the reality of the
impact when it comes to taking uh direct
action and we can see that today in
communities which are hit for example by
extraordinarily high summer temperatures
causing wildfires uh and substantial
economic and infrastructural damage and
yet there are still elements of those
communities who deny that it's anything
to do with global uh climate change or
global climate change impacts
um
in the past what tends to happen uh and
it's
it seems to be a general rule
is that the people who are best able to
weather serious dramatic challenges are
those with the best access to resources
i the social
and wealth elites how one defines those
elites varies by social and economic
system of course
they don't have to be narrow
groups at the top of the of the pyramid
as it were they could be much more
substantial numbers of people
um
but motivating those elites to change
tends to be much harder because their
whole
life system if you like and the basis
for their situation in society and more
generally depends upon the status quo
and asking them to alter the status quo
in a way which will directly impact
their own
um opportunities
uh is is really very problematic
um
so there are two two problems really the
people who have least invested in a
society i the people who are most
underprivileged
tend to be those who are also
um at least willing to make changes
because they see no point
and at the other end you've got the
people who won't make changes because
they see the potential damage it'll do
to their own situation
um and as a historian i really don't
have an answer to how to to deal with
either of those uh issues i suspect the
people
um who are least privileged um at least
with least access to resources um are
going to be easier to persuade uh to
help make changes than those who have
most to lose um which are the very
wealthy and the the social elites
again i want to be clear that we have to
define elites quite carefully it's not
simply those with most money or those
with most power
it has to be sociologically a little bit
more refined and nuanced than that but
you get the point
absolutely i thought you put it well
when you talked about people who benefit
from the status quo um it's hard to you
know encourage action um when that's the
case uh i want to bring sunita into this
so um john has kind of talked about how
these dynamics play out over the course
of history um you you've talked about
more recent history and in your work um
over decades on this on this issue um so
when it comes to
motivating change as rohini put it
earlier
not just individual activism but systems
level change we need action across the
spectrum um and john just outlined why
it's harder to get some people to act
than others so um sunita can you just
kind of comment on um
whether you see this as an opportunity
and what the impact of kovid might be on
this space
you know i i i agree with rohini i mean
the fact is that kobit is actually uh
should really worry us in terms of
global action i mean i i don't think any
one of us at least
i never thought of we would see
disruption at the scale that we saw the
last two years
i mean we all locked up at homes
economies have collapsed livelihoods
have gone
we're all roaming around with mosques
that we would all have resisted there
are tons of economies and yes in delhi
we saw blue skies and you know we
celebrated the sound of birds and we saw
the that nature reclaimed itself but at
the cost
uh which clearly is something that
people will today
in my view on one hand we are
celebrating clean air but on the other
hand people are realizing that the cost
of that was just so extraordinary
that um there is also a push back
against it
so um um and and it is a fact that we
have the this is the worst time in the
world the leadership in the world
literally sucks
okay we could not have thought about a
world in which disruption of this scale
and yet you have vaccine racism
happening today yet you have a divided
world i mean what does it tell us about
the future of climate change i mean the
good news is yes g7 goes and talks about
an interdependent world they've
understood interdependence
that they had never thought would happen
uh when the you know when the virus
moves across nations and you know we're
all connected but that's what climate
change is about that is exactly what
climate change is about and that is
exactly why the world has to come
together with the leadership that
demands and as john has put it very
clearly i mean it is the poor who are
the victims of climate change but they
are the ones who do not have a voice in
the discussions they don't have a voice
to say that they need to do something
about it let's be clear they understand
climate change i mean the farmers of
india are not there they may not know
the fancy word climate change but they
understand that there is something afoot
that this is serious they need to do
something about it and they make the
links uh with uh the way weather is
changing that and if you explain a
little more they will understand
pollution and yes i i think they will be
a desire to change but there is a huge
i think it's much more to do with not
just the system
of uh the economy but it's much more to
do
with our inability to actually do things
at scale which is different
i mean that's the opportunity that i
think we have in india i mean you know
when we started our work on air
pollution the the entire approach was
how would you fix and rightly so
how would you fix the tailpipe of cars
how would you do
better emission control but what we
realize soon enough is that you know
barely 15 percent of delhi drives
and there is a common airshirt and that
if you have 85 percent of delhi driving
as they do in washington there is no
road space there is no airship and that
is why people in the us have you know
their emissions their transport related
emissions today have jeopardized and
brought us all at the brink of this
catastrophe so if people in delhi have
to understand that unless we reinvent
our mobility system we don't get clean
air and the the transformation of the
mobility system is has to be done at
scale you know we are still talking
about a few battery vehicles here and a
few buses here and all that you know
when csc worked on its first generation
air pollution reform we talked about
moving to compressed natural gas and 100
000
vehicles moved to gas in a matter of a
year
that scale of transformation brought
impact and that's really what we need in
our countries today and that's what we
need in the world so but it's also got
to do with this enormous
you know for me the biggest battle is to
get the idea understood and the
possibility of change understood because
there is so much mental authority to
think of something different
and to think that it is possible and i
think it's a lot to do with the technic
technology systems
the education systems that we have and
of course the huge vested interest i
mean moving to gas simple as that was so
difficult because of the interest in
diesel moving out of coal in delhi today
is uh was was possible because we just
pushed it through but moving our coal in
our industries is difficult because one
we don't have reliable power and two um
uh it's the cheapest form of fuel
available so i think it's a it's it's a
tough time in the world catherine a
little longer answer but just to explain
to you it's a tough time in the world
and you know kobe has actually pushed us
in my view
uh backwards rather than forward because
there is going to be a desperation now
and unfortunately that desperation will
mean we will reinvest in the brown
economy rather than the green even
though we will talk about green but we
will drown and that's what we have to
fight and we have to make sure that we
can call it out otherwise we are all in
it
for
you know we'll all be saying the nice
sweet words and nothing will change
please go ahead nick i was just going to
say quickly that uh this framing of
investing in the green not the brown and
uh the desperation could
lead to investment in the brown not the
green you have to fight it nick i think
your research kind of speaks to how
well i would just like to to put some
numbers i i think um the the prior two
points i i very
highly share the pessimism of what
covett has revealed about the capability
for international cooperation but to put
a number on it the right um order of
magnitude for a number for renewable
energy investment that's needed
worldwide is something like a hundred
trillion dollars so arena for example
says 131 trillion dollars um and that
number is kind of inconceivably large
you know nobody encounters a number like
that in their day-to-day life but a
basis for comparison would be how much
would it cost to vaccinate every person
in the world against covet um and that
would be something like
70 billion depending on you know what
price you negotiate in the scale but say
there's seven billion people and it's
ten bucks a dose uh the eu negotiated
twelve dollars a dose probably it would
be cheaper than that because you know
you could you could bring it down so
what that means is that the difference
between the scale
the solution's point of investment
that's needed for climate change versus
the scale that would eliminate orbit
is about 1
500 times
so
that is how much larger uh the problem
is just in in money terms and that's the
kind of reason to be a little bit
pessimistic if we can't get our act
together and if say the u.s or china
unilaterally is not willing to step up
and say here's 70 billion dollars to
eliminate covet effectively from the
world then what's the the prospect
um now that's extremely pessimistic i'm
not personally quite that pessimistic
and i think the reason why is that there
have been sources there have been
movements in a private sector especially
that bring down the cost of renewable
energy bring down the cost of these
alternatives so even well governments
have been twiddling their thumbs
and sort of not accomplishing terribly
much there has been a massive wave of
renewable energy investment which is in
part you know accelerated this sort of
adoption of electricity and other fuels
in developing countries so that's that's
the sort of positive case which is that
even as the the leaders are doing very
little uh innovation and falls in cost
of these technology as for the vaccines
have made it at least feasible to talk
about working at the scale that's
required
yeah absolutely and i actually wanted to
um bring something up ahead of this call
um rohini and i were talking about some
of the things we wanted to get into and
i know uh one thing she mentioned was
carbon capture and the economics of
carbon capture and linking to what i
thought was a very helpful piece that
i'll just quickly reference talking
about how
stopping emissions stops making the
climate worse but repairing the damage
insofar as repair is possible will
require more than emissions cuts and
that gets to the role that technology
can play that nick was alluding to um
things like carbon removal
solar geoengineering
rohini is that something you wanted to
touch on just in terms of what a fair
deal will look like at cop26 where
technology comes into this and um how it
goes beyond just stopping emissions
so i actually wanted to pose the
question because i'm relatively ignorant
and i felt our
panelists may have something to say on
it but i feel very often right now we're
still talking about cutting emissions
and so we spend a lot of time talking
about
you know renewable energy and issues
like that but you know we've already
seen the effects of climate change and
even if we cut emissions down to zero
today we have all this carbohydrate
remains and so i'd be curious to hear
from i think sunita john and nick how
should we think about how soon this is
going to get on the agenda and again how
should we think about uh just deal there
because that is very clearly something
that you could argue these historic
contributions matter a lot when you
start thinking about removing the carbon
in the air
so maybe i'll ask anita because i
thought about it thinking about code 26.
so roy i think that's a very fascinating
question and i think we need to really
work about this because yes we are
beyond just saying that you know we're
going to be able to cut the emissions at
the scale that is needed and so that's
where the whole concept of net zero has
come in to say we're going to live
within
uh what would you know the amount of
emissions that we put out we're going to
find ways of being able to soak it up
capture it bury it
kill it i don't know what else we're
going to do we're going to find some way
to make it magically disappear and if it
can disappear we will be net zero now
when you look at the proposals rohini
and i think i mean i have been one of
the people opposing net zero and people
have often asked me why would you oppose
such a good idea i mean why would
anybody say net zero is bad i mean one
is bad from an equity point of view the
fact is ipcc said that we need to reach
net zero by 2050 for the world
now that doesn't mean that india and the
us can have ever
the same timeline i mean u.s with its
historical emissions and if you look at
the carbon budget i mean i'm not even
going to go there i mean i think that
discussion is today
so over that we shouldn't even waste our
time uh being donald trump again okay
and try and talk about how your india is
equivalent to the us so i mean i'm not
even going to go there uh but i think
the the big issue
with net zero is what really exists to
be able to soak up the emissions now
this is where the concept of again
we always keep inventing these new words
and then people have to decipher them
and make some sense out of them
nature-based solutions so what is
nature-based solutions we're going to
plant trees and we already have planted
trees and they're going to soak it up
now where are we going to plant trees
the worst
forests of the world and the lands of
the world actually exist in the
developing world because it's much
cheaper to plant there
there is no cost of land uh we can we
can plant massive amounts of trees there
and that's where the conversation is
going to happen in glasgow which is the
market basement mechanisms bringing this
together to say that countries will be
able to pay
for the sequestration of carbon it's a
sort of new clean development mechanism
that is um in the works now what does
all that mean
and i think that's where the just
transition must and the whole concept of
equity and justice must be part of it i
mean the biggest issue with and and i i
know all of you will understand this
biggest issue is land rights biggest
issue is who controls the land who will
benefit from it i mean we want to plant
trees in a country like india we're very
clear that we cannot have only
conservation oriented forestry we need
development oriented forestry but we
also know that that money
must be in the hands of communities and
we also need to understand the land
tenure rights where will communities
benefit from it or not and so i think
there are a lot of big issues that we
haven't even begun to understand
and already and what what we need to and
again i'm just saying this because i
think we
need to be able to call this out to say
we're already got a new words out there
net zero nature based solutions all that
sounds as if it's going to happen
tomorrow because these disruptive
technologies are just going to come in
and everything will disappear it's a
tough world and we need to understand
that the poor in the world i mean nick
talked about renewable energy let's be
clear nick in my part of the world solar
is still too expensive for the poorest
in my country okay and let's also be
very clear yes the grid has reached
across india which is an amazing uh feat
but the fact is electricity has not
because people are too poor to be able
to pay for that electricity and that
comes from cheap dirty coal
so we have to understand that and this
is india then we need to talk about
africa so we need to get some really
hard questions there hardy issues there
and for once we should not allow this
discussion to be taken over with just
some nice genteel words some nice nice
things to say and we go home
very powerful a call to action ahead of
cop 26. nick i want to bring you into
this um sunita mentioned that you know
there's there's the rhetoric at cop26 uh
about net zero nature-based solutions um
these disruptive technologies but it
seems quite disconnected from the
reality on the ground and as you
mentioned solar is still too expensive
for the poorest in india so price is a
huge part of this and can you expand on
what you see as a way forward and does
cop 26 get at this or is that really
perhaps not the right forum to find
something
so um it does but very indirectly um and
you know
politely i would submit i think that the
renewable picture is better than it has
been um and it's changing day by day so
you know the numbers in india the most
recent solar auctions are at something
like two and a half rupees a kilowatt
hour and most um coal plants have
levelized costs of three and a half or
or four rupees so it's possible
that that energy can actually be cheaper
and thereby you know enable
electrification
now that needs a lot of sort of
an enabling environment a regulatory
environment to support those things but
the prices are are very very close very
competitive nowadays
catherine can i just come in and
make
slight you know let's let's get the
reality the fact is yes we're all very
excited i have a real proponent of uh
renewable and i do believe that's the
future but let's sort of get a reality
check the fact is the plf of the solar
is 20 the plf of coal is much higher so
yes the levelized cost of solar becomes
cheaper but there is uptrend capital
cost too you do not get as many units
from a solar plant as you get from a
coal-based plant so it is still it is
still and let's be clear this is why in
india we've not seen the commissioning
rate of solar as much as we'd like
and this is in spite of the fact this is
one program that the government of india
is completely committed to and rightly
so
and but there is a basic issue of the
ability to pay for power and that's
about poverty and covet has only made it
worse not better
and the availability is um
certainly a concern and that's something
that gets worse as the scale of solar
grows if when solar is a small part of
your energy mix it doesn't matter but
looking ahead that's likely to be a
bigger problem um you know india is
maybe at eight or ten percent renewable
generation today if that reached to 25
or 30 percent it would make the power
grid much more difficult
to run
can i just jump in quickly catherine um
so earlier nick um suggested that he was
a little bit more optimistic than some
of his rather pessimistic statistics
indicated um and then um with what
sunita then said later on um i'm feeling
more pessimistic again but it strikes me
that one of the the framing questions
that we need to be asking as well which
everyone's aware of is the geopolitical
aspect because on the one hand we have
we have we're asking some of the right
questions and we're actually developing
some of the correct answers and we we're
costing them and we can see
what they might achieve if we can apply
them but actually instrumentalizing them
it meets a major block on the one hand
with geopolitics and the competition
between state
interests
whatever the politicians at cop 26 might
say
they all have to
consider their own particular local
political interests and political
survival as individuals
on the one hand and on the other um we
have been below the level of states but
not really much less visible
competing
global multinationals
who
we're almost at the stage now where we
have an asimov like um world run by
giant corporations
which we know can have enormous impacts
particularly on less powerful states in
terms of influencing them
and one only has to think of the way in
which from the point of view of a state
china is beginning to affect the
economies of many african countries now
um both
to the advantage of those countries on
the one hand but certainly to the to the
geostrategic advantage of the people's
republic of china on the other which
then complicates um
the world geopolitical situation
increases tensions between superpowers
and so forth we all we all know that
how do we build that into our framework
and how do we address those questions
uh seems to me to be a fundamental
problem and from the historian's point
of view that's always been even before
people were globally aware
um
but let's say in more recent
pre-modernity stay in the 17th and 18th
centuries when imperial
european imperial states
were understanding the nature of the
potentials for global power and control
even at this point
these
these factors were directly impacting on
local and regional sustainabilities
and their economies
and i'm i'm wondering you know the the
number of intersecting problems that
we're having to confront in order to
thrash out some simple policy decisions
and obtain the investment we need to
contribute towards that you know
hundreds of trillions of dollar costs
um
seems to me
not quite insurmountable
but frighteningly problematic
and as long as we're working on
um a highly divided
um uh um
nationalistic geopolitical scenario
that's always going to be a major
sticking point whatever the promises
that might be held out
at a an international conference or
congress uh such as cop 26
behind that as soon as the
the people who do the speaking and make
the promises go back home they're
confronted by their own local realities
and we all have been seen on at least
three occasions since the 1960s
how many of the promises that were made
were simply written back on really very
rapidly
i want to bring nick into this um just
because actually nick has to go teach an
undergraduate class in just a moment
which we all certainly understand but
nick i saw you nodding along and i just
love any reaction you have or just final
thoughts and then we'll bring in uh some
questions from audience you know um i
think professor holden's point
fundamentally is you know it depends in
this pledge and review and the nature of
the the cop on the interests of the
individual countries and what they will
sort of be able to carry out at home in
the u.s is the worst example of a
laggard um because you know its
commitments have always been very modest
uh if not sort of altogether negligible
and yet it's not even lived up to the
commitments it made
um you know for example the the green
climate fund which was one of the
mechanisms conceived
to transfer resources to developing
countries for adaptation and mitigation
investments we're supposed to have a
headline you know value of 100 billion
dollars till date there's been something
like eight billion committed uh the us
initially offered three and then gave
one uh so
you know it's not promising enough and
then not living up to promises and so
we've reached this odd point in the in
the cop rounds where
you know the the sort of historical um
countries responsible for mostly
emissions have done very little and yet
you know india has adopted a coal cess
has set these ambitious renewable energy
targets
um china though leading the world in
carbon consumption has also sort of
increased dramatically its investments
in renewable energy and is supplying the
world with with solar panels to get this
done so i think there's a time where
you know the us and europe in particular
need to sort of walk the walk and you
know an ounce of walk is worth a pound
of talk for for the next round to show
that they're actually serious
yeah
thank you nick
um i want to go ahead and move to some
questions from our audience and uh this
this is something we've hinted at but um
this question tackles it head-on so this
is from someone who's doing a study on
climate justice and capitalism and asks
whether our speakers could speak to the
global capitalist system and whether it
disenfranchises the world's most
vulnerable communities in terms of
climate justice so i want to begin with
rohini and sunita and then
perhaps we can go back in time a little
bit and talk with john about uh really
whether addressing inequality is
necessary when it comes to solving the
politics of climate change but first
this question on capitalism
and whether it disenfranchises the
world's most vulnerable in terms of
climate justice i think it tackles what
we're discussing head on and um maybe
we'll begin with rohini on that
sure i mean it it's hard to not agree
so i'm trying to figure out how do i
give a more nuance to reply to that
so maybe it's maybe a question think
about is where is the climate different
from all the other ways in which the
poor are dissent enfranchised by the
global capitalist system and i think i'd
go back to one thing that sunita talked
about which is really the tragedy of the
commons so i think sunita talked about
you know thinking about communities and
forests and you know it is the case that
the poor the world over are much more
dependent on agriculture on land and
those are systems that
are particularly um
are going to particularly badly if when
they're poorly defined property rights
for instance over water
or for instance if
someone can come along and say i'm going
to
grow palm oil because there's a big
market for it
so i think perhaps one way into this
question of thinking about climate
justice is to really ask
can we start thinking about the ways in
which we give legal rights to the
world's poor communities on these lands
because that's what capitalism asks it
asks us to trade in a marketplace where
people have rights and they can trade
and we very often don't give those
depending on natural resources
the same kind of rights as someone say
buying a house in new haven
damita any reactions to that or this
broader question
yeah no i think rohini's said it i mean
only difference i have is rohini some of
those rights will be little complicated
because it's not just private rights
it's community rights and the problem of
i mean the problem with the the the
climate change and the problem with
forests and grazing lands and water
bodies
is the fact that we need to redefine the
system of rights and move beyond
individual rights
we need individual benefits we need
cooperation but often rights have to be
held
almost like a trust and that's where the
problem with the modern capitalist
system has been that it only understands
one kind of right and and and that
really is part of the problem but i
think
one of the and catherine i'm also
struggling and frankly i don't want to
go down in your panel as being the most
pessimistic
person so i'm also trying to um and and
this question gives me a way to be able
to answer to say
to me i mean i work in india uh my my my
entire work is here fighting for clean
air clean water
garbage
forests all the rest of it and i see
progress and so let me be very clear i
don't i don't see the same level of
progress that i
would like because then i'm an activist
i want more than i will get
at any time but i see more progress in
india than i see globally
and i see more progress here because of
the imperative of change i mean we are
today increasingly seeing name be on its
head uh not in my backyard has always
been not in my backyard of the rich
and it is the poor whose lands the the
muck has gone to and that is where john
talked about the you know the the elite
i mean broadly it's in my view it's the
people who call the sharks and say not
in my backyard when you have an
incinerator a whole base plant or a
waste disposal system whatever it always
moves to somebody else's backyard and
that's the classic problem of the way
globally we have also managed our
pollution um and and
you know it's not the u.s it's china
which is producing it or india any in
india it's produced because it's so
cheap and why is it cheap because labor
and environmental conditions are given a
um
a go ahead i mean they don't need to
account for it now i see that changing
here because of the fact that you're
getting more and more what i call the
nimby of the poor where it is the poor
who are saying not in my backyard not in
my backyard can the city of
tiruvanthapuram in kerala dump its waist
small thing but the fact is the poor
village woman is saying that and the
villagers are getting together and
saying that and that actually turns the
entire waste system on its head because
if the rich can't dump their waste in
the lands of the poor they need to dump
it on their own front yard and if they
have to dump it on their own front yard
they will have to clean it up so i think
to some extent this is the power of
democracy this is the power of being
able to give a voice to people and the
rights to people to be able to ask
demand and that's where the change is
coming in my part of the world that's so
that's the biggest trigger for change
real change that we are seeing so i see
if you can do that globally i don't see
it's possible but nevertheless i see
that's the way okay
thank you sumita uh we have questions
coming in and we're we're quickly
running out of time but john i did want
to come back to you
um not necessarily to talk about the
capitalist system as it exists today but
this connection between inequality uh
and and the politics of climate change
and how uh we can make changes and
design institutions that address not
just climate change but inequality
i think the first thing is that if one
looks at the the the capitalist system
as a global system
today then
it is a deeply oppressive system and an
excluding system many respects um
in theory one could one can theorize a
a capitalist world system that is less
uh inegalitarian
um but i think by its very nature that
sort of
market economic
system requires
um
the necessity for some people to be
kept if you like at the level of
being excluded um in some respects from
a range of different types of resource
and access to resource and facilities on
the other hand it also depends upon
consumerism
and one of the major problems that we
wasn't mentioned earlier but it's it's a
key issue is the the the the mass
consumerism
of the privileged parts of the world
which is one of the major drivers for um
both um
air pollution and industrial output
so it's both it has both good and bad
sides how to square that circle that's a
whole different issue do we need
to
um
get rid of elites
well it's a nice idea i suppose if one
isn't a member of the elite um
but we'll always need to either choose
elect select or somehow have people who
can speak for the larger majority
however they're selected or elected and
that takes us to a whole different
ballgame about political systems and so
forth which we probably
shouldn't um get into
um
i think what one can aim for though i
mean the the real issue which i've
mentioned in our private discussions
before is baseline inequality what makes
societies in the past least able to
resist substantial environmental
challenge
and the greater the degree of baseline
inequality the less resilient and the
less sustainable they turn out to be it
doesn't mean to say that in the short
term some elements of those societies
don't do very well out of change and
those elements are usually elites
but it does mean that the the greater
the distribution of wealth across a
society even if you have an elite and
and an underprivileged group at one at
the other end of society the greater the
degree of distribution of wealth the
more flexible the more resilient the
less brittle
a societal system uh tends to be and
that means it can
overcome
challenges quite substantial challenges
both short and long term more
successfully again there are always
costs to resilience you can't have
resilience without paying a cost
um
and that that's the basic message that
certainly uh we learned from the
historical record maybe in the future
that can be different if we organize our
resources and access to resources
differently from the way we currently do
so i think
maybe getting rid of elites is a nice
idea but it's not likely to happen
anytime soon but what we can do and we
can demonstrate that this is possible in
certain um
certain
sectors of the world today is have a
much better re a much better
distribution of of social wealth and
access to social wealth and resources
than we currently have in many countries
and it's that extreme difference between
the very very small super wealthy elite
and a much larger mass of people who are
more or less entirely excluded from the
possibility of achieving access to the
resources that make for a healthy
and sustainable
life
if we can get rid of that difference we
already take a substantial step forward
thank you john i want to end with a
question from the audience and perhaps
uh even broaden the lens of this
question because i think it's something
we should all consider and leaders at
cop26 should consider but the question
is
what are steps you think youth can or
should take to engage in climate
activism in a more class slash wealth
conscious way um so how can youth or how
can we all take steps um to when we
think about climate think a bit in terms
of a fair deal um based on all the
dynamics we discussed today so with just
a couple minutes left quickly i'll go to
sunita and john and then we'll rock with
rohini but sunita any reactions to that
great question yeah i just want to say
catherine i'm so impressed by the words
of the youth of today
and i have to i have to say that you
know i i have been a climate activist
since 1990 and it has been a very tough
job and i have literally been in tears
in many meetings
to try and get the word of equity
justice and to get people to understand
why it is important and i still believe
the establishment
ngos who work civil society works on
this i failed to get them to understand
but when i see the voices of the youth
today they understand they're rooted in
the politics of climate change and i'm
seeing a diversity of voices from the
youth as well so i think hats off to the
youth of this of the world today not
only are they talking truth to power but
they are
rooting the conversation on climate in
the reality of climate in the politics
of climate and that is critical for us
to move ahead so i i would only say do
more of what you're doing
thank you sunita and i believe that
question came from a yale undergrad so
thank you for that john any reaction to
that
well yeah i mean i think um uh younger
people have really set the um
established an initiative and
i can't ever claim to have been a
climate activist as such although i've
always been politically active and i
guess nowadays the two things have to
overlap to a very large extent
um but i think some of the movements
that one sees
such as this extinction rebellion
some of the other youth youth-based
movements but which have also attracted
a lot of support from
older generations
and which across social class as well
the people involved from working class
middle class
backgrounds um
of course different
different cultures define
social and cultural class in different
ways when one talks about middle class
in america it means something quite
different from when we talk about middle
class in england for example
nevertheless
the the activism i think spreads and
it's contagious and it's a good thing
and we have to accept that activism has
to be a broad church there are going to
be some aspects of it which we as
individuals might not like
um
but in other aspects which we feel are
not activist enough
but the crucial point is to make an
impact and to force
uh people to pay more attention to the
problems and issues that we face and
that's what political activism has
always been about it hasn't necessarily
been to directly
uh bring about a change in itself it's
been about attracting enough attention
to persuade other people to get involved
and realize as an issue and do something
about it either in their voting patterns
or in their daily lives or whatever it
happens to be
thank you john and rohini your thoughts
on this to close this out i know we're
out of time so i keep it short so i
think i'll just say something that was
perhaps implicit in what john was saying
which is
you can't ignore the state or the
politics of the state in the end so i
think a lot of activism is
is great and this extinction rebellion
are great but it reminds me in
development we've had a
long history in fact even at yale like
these are the most active student groups
as effective altruists and i think the
thing i always tell them is you have to
engage with the state i mean in the end
it isn't about there isn't that much
foreign aid in the world for four
countries it's about getting them to get
their state to work so
i think
the youth are doing great things and
they should just make sure they vote and
they push for change within the
political system as well
thank you rohini uh we are out of time i
want to thank you all so much for
joining us again this conversation was
part of a larger series the yale
development dialogues and our next event
will focus on health equity it'll take
place on thursday october 28th so stay
tuned for details on that uh thank you
to our co-host the yale economic growth
center jackson institute for global
affairs and history department thank you
so much to our panelists and thanks to
all of you for joining
you